thank you
[Music]
all right who uh keep real guys who here
cheated academically
nope dude that was my jam strong it's
not like that
once in a while but not really what was
your preference what was your way in
Algebra 2 there was a small um Japanese
girl that sat in front of me and she was
like she was really smart and she was
actually a year below us
and her name was April nishinaka I
remember she was one of like very few uh
Asian people in my high school and she
was so little I could see over her
shoulder nice oh so I just sat behind
her and she I knew her older brother
because her older brother went to school
with my sister so like we knew each
other and I would just
lean over and then just copy your work
so she wasn't even doing it like as a
teammate no like he just told her that
means for Algebra 2 you'd have to copy
the graphs and everything well that's
why it was great I could see over
shoulder because I had to show my work
yeah you copied her work too I'd be like
I'll get these ones wrong cool and
that's how I got through Algebra I don't
remember none of my algebra you remember
Algebra I don't remember none of that
[ __ ] no you [ __ ] throw Albert algebra
equation at me I'll be like man I can't
I don't know what the [ __ ] is this you
know it really it really depends on the
teacher I sucked at math up until I met
a teacher in like Community College dude
same with me yeah yeah for real and then
like this this old dude and he just
talked to me and I ended up like I went
from like C's and D's in math and also
after this guy I got A's and math like
moving forward same thing with me yeah
the right teacher can just change
everything the way they explained it or
is it the way they gave it more meaning
you know what for me the only difference
was that this community college teacher
had explained that he used to suck at
math I think that's all you needed to
hear oh to be honest yeah it wasn't the
teacher maybe the student just got older
I never had no teacher act like she was
wasn't born knowing all the quadratic
formulas yeah especially in like math or
like sciency yeah like they're so
[ __ ] arrogant yeah it's the arrogance
it like turned me off from feeling like
it was attainable to understand it and
that's all that stops you mentally right
espec when you're a kid you think oh I'm
not a math person yeah oh I'm a history
person I'm an English person whatever
but in reality it's just like
everyone sucks at it for a period of
time right you know and I also I also
was uh did a really big cheat in Algebra
2 class I had my buddy who's on my uh
who wasn't my um on my dance team
obviously in high school but we ended up
being on the same team college but in
high school I remember showing for pop
quiz and not knowing those Pop Quiz I
didn't study for [ __ ] and he was like
he's like dude don't worry I got you I
was like what the [ __ ] does that even
mean right we're like sitting there it's
like math you can't just get paid like
how do you how do you I got you and then
he [ __ ] like 30 minutes I'm just
sweating balls in this whole class and
then finally he's like
and he switches tests with me might as
well
he takes my testimony and pencil what a
[ __ ] G and when the teacher's not
only switches it back and then [ __ ]
race and re-roaches damn that was the
most most intense copying I ever did on
that one why is this hooked you up so
much because I'm [ __ ] pretty cool
Bart they're pretty awesome to people
usually I can't wrap his head around it
why would a friend do that for you some
friends are just friends they don't need
something in return they just do things
for each other and that's how they get
things in return you still talk to this
guy yeah rarely though uh anyways Point
what a good friend uh point is there was
a teacher recently who created a uh
fairly ingenious exam question in order
to find cheaters and was able to catch
14 of 100 students that would have been
me bro what is this question what 14
cheater yeah yeah that's very good
psychological because here's the thing
nowadays right when we had to cheat
we're all talking about like when we
were cheating what we were doing we're
like looking over the shoulder what are
our problems oh how did you recoption
now your [ __ ] cell phones they have
everything there's a calculator remember
our calculators were like textbook size
now they got [ __ ] little yeah they
have they have Google available
everywhere and yeah this [ __ ] in
our math class and it's like where do
you put it why is that even there and
you got to sit by the window so the
solar panel could get some power no yeah
look what am I in the dark part of the
cloud my battery is dead or like you
thought it was super ingenious the first
time somebody like wrote answers on the
inside of a water bottle label that's a
good one right but those ancient tactics
have all been usurped by technology so
much easier right and it can't be
stopped so this one teacher started
realizing
that only on exam days every [ __ ] kid
needed to go to the bathroom all of a
sudden all of a sudden right every kid
like half the class always needs to
someone to use the restroom but you
can't you can't say no and you can't
like fall into the restaurant there's
like limitations to this thing right so
his teacher thinks about this idea he's
getting [ __ ] annoyed and pissed off
so he's all right I'm gonna write this
test and then on this test I want to put
down one question that is impossible to
answer it doesn't even provide it here
by the way I think probably because you
can continue using it yeah it doesn't
doesn't put down the question but goes
to the websites that students often look
up in order to find answers for certain
quiz and tests because that's what
people be doing and put fake answer on
and then
engineered a fake answer that was close
enough to the truth that a student who
was going to the Russian wouldn't have
enough time to fully look into
and anybody who got that answer was
immediately given a zero on the test
anybody who just got the the question
wrong in general was still given a score
for that wow I thought deep it went deep
into it he had his ta [ __ ] code the
answer in like these websites and [ __ ]
like that that's smart and then 14
students got that answer so imagine
[ __ ] like putting together this test
and being like there's no way anybody's
gonna be able to answer this and I'll
put a fake answer online especially yeah
especially when you have like take-home
tests or whatever like because you get
those in college a lot or you have an
open note open book test yeah so that's
actually [ __ ] genius do you guys
think tests are even effective in
helping people to learn [ __ ] not learn
[ __ ] but keep them disciplined yeah oh
yeah like you have to teach you
consequences and it teaches you rankings
and it teaches you that kind of system
and to know your [ __ ] on like before the
class ends it teaches you depends on the
subject too
So like um when I was like pre-med and I
was studying for the MCAT like every
single question technically everything
you need to know to answer that question
is on that page so you can't even really
cheat because it's the utilization of
those tools is what you have to know and
memorize and it's impossible to like
like read something really quick and
understand how it's not a cram thing
like geometry Fox so for example yeah
like so for example like every so in the
uh like on the MCAT it's not like oh
here's a chemistry question or here's a
physics question it's a physical
sciences question yeah so it'll be like
let's say this light passes through this
prism at whatever velocity and then it
hits this and this theme boils to a
certain temperature what happens to this
chemical now so it's like it and it
tells you everything it tells you the
boiling point of the chemical here it
tells you whatever over here but it's
your your grasp of the entire context
that helps you solve this problem and
it's not something you can go oh just go
[ __ ] memorize like how gases turn
into liquid or whatever here and then
memorize how things pass through prism
here you know what I mean so like I
think in that case it works really
really well because you know that you
have to know not only just the
memorization but also the utilization of
it to even enter into that test
ask that question ever in any test yeah
that was a that was a complicated
whatever that was
a prism
you ever been to prison before
they spelled prison are you boiling
light yeah you ever seen how light
passes through a prison
it does it down here
I always forget that Bart's like really
smart I'm not interested he just goes
the opposite way trust me
the best questions of the day
yeah
I also got caught cheating uh in uh
I don't know if I did I mention this I
went to my cousin's wedding recently and
I got reunited with the old high school
friend I hadn't seen like 20 years I
hate those
people are those the point is uh this
dude
this dude who I I haven't seen or talked
to in like 20 plus years
um it was interesting because now it's
grown as adults now he's like a surgeon
and [ __ ] like that right and I'm a
[ __ ] dancer [ __ ] made it um we we
ended up talking and then we're drinking
at the open bar and the next thing you
know I'm like apologizing for something
that happened like over 20 years ago and
I was like damn you [ __ ] bullied him
or what no why why did our friendship
fall off and it's because of one moment
I was real when I transferred over to my
high school I didn't have any friends I
didn't go to the junior high before
anything like that so you know when you
randomly pick a friend you end up like
all right that's my close friends the
only friend that has you're my closest
friend so we spent all the time together
we play Magic the Gathering in the
science classroom during break I was a
[ __ ] losers but anyways that still
sounds fun this guy was smart as [ __ ]
though right still smart as [ __ ] and we
got honors English together and then
there was this [ __ ] uh this paper
that needed to be due
um for whatever stupid ass young Anthony
reason you know sometimes you when you
you copy or you cheat you just do it the
most wrong way there's like a if you say
if I say it now you're gonna like dull
you're such an idiot but for some reason
I chose the play drives like an entire
like three sentences at the end word for
word in it you know what I mean as an
adult you're like why the [ __ ] would you
do that but you get lazy sometimes
you're a bad criminal dude thank you I'm
gonna judge you uh I'm down for dumbart
to come back down
in fat bar yeah fat bar is my favorite
but uh I I don't like bad criminals this
this was one of those English teachers
who like um it was you know in a very
oxymoronic way it was like a dope
teacher to have but then on the other
sense like kind of a little bit on the
[ __ ] high horse a little cut block
and he'd be like look guys I really like
you guys but because I like you I have
to give you the maximum penalty for this
you want to teach you guys a lesson you
need to teach his lesson so took us to
the principal both of us got a year and
a half probation oh a year and a half a
year and a half of academic probation
went on a record so certain colleges
weren't able
I was suspended for like five days
for plagiarizing a couple of sentences
could have taught you a lesson though
right why was your friend also involved
in this ring because it was his paper
yeah oh they assumed he let him or
something yeah which he did but yeah so
he could have like not got into the
College of choice is that why like he
hated you you never hated me for it but
just the idea that like after that his
mom was like you can't hang out with
Anthony and then our friendship just
like never
went any farther but it was crazy to see
him like 20 plus years I didn't be like
oh dude it's good to see you and
obviously we're adults and nobody gives
a [ __ ] about like that moment the mom's
like you don't talk to that boy I shook
off the bad influence and that's why
he's a surgeon and you're a dancer she's
like I could have been a dancer such a
severe punishment the same thing
happened to me that was it even a final
it was just a regular [ __ ] thing
that's gonna affect your future that's
[ __ ] crazy and he's like I like you
so let me [ __ ] your future the hardest
way possible but it's for your own good
ah Anthony Lee was gonna be fine he knew
he saw the potential again after that
[ __ ] that teacher dude jump his ass
right now the real problem is the
teacher dude when I was in seventh grade
and I went to a Christian school and I
copied from this girl uh the the copy
the Bible the Bible bro and I said it
was my own work
so many run-ons dude no I copied her my
word was like it was like a Bible
crossword thing and I just didn't do it
so I was like yo let me see your [ __ ]
and I was like copying it and then the
teacher got me and then she suspended
they suspended me for like a day and
like everything I just always felt back
because I was like dude she was like a
really sweet girl and she was like a
goody good girl you know and her mom was
like a sub at that school oh dude and
like I ended up going to high school
with her later and I always felt like
she still [ __ ] hates me do you ever
apologize yeah I did I did but I got her
suspended I got suspended first why
didn't you [ __ ] copy from girl
give me that [ __ ] dude
give me that or else yeah I was a robot
and it's a [ __ ] Christian crossword
puzzle it's like I could have done it
serious you know what I did
um I didn't cheat but when I first
learned quotations I was like this is
the legal way
I turned in a [ __ ] pretty good essay
where the only thing original was my
name in the intro and the [ __ ] whole
body was just we did a book report and I
just [ __ ] said oh you know it's like
this was a great you know it was like a
great
um moment when this happened end quote
and then it's like three [ __ ] pages I
just wrote word for word and I put quote
as a citation yeah
F obviously right
I thought I was super clever at sixth
grade because I was like how do I fill
up five pages because you know they
always tell you about this many pages so
I'm like well I found a way of making
five pages that got me in big trouble in
English in high school because you had
you know when you were reading a book in
class every so often you had to write a
paper on however portion you were on and
I knew the teacher never read it I knew
it was always a Tas who are my friends
so I started just writing dumb [ __ ] in
Philippines with just stupid [ __ ] so my
friends would laugh knowing that it was
nothing about the book that's why I got
so good at writing it's good like
perfect short because they're not gonna
read all that [ __ ] so then like
eventually I guess at some point the
teacher started reading those and I was
already way deep in my [ __ ] and I I
this is exactly what I wrote and this is
why I got in trouble I said like
wouldn't it be so cool so there's a book
about [ __ ] a girl in a ship I put
wouldn't it be so cool if if you just
had a gun filled with blanks and when
you had road rage you could just shoot
blanks at people
this is what I wrote and then my teacher
made me have a meeting with my parents
and her to like discuss some like weird
rage issue I had and I was like no I
don't know if it's worse to say this but
I've just been bullshitting a little
year you're not supposed to read this so
I had her look at my old papers that she
never saw and I'm like see I do this
every time
so why aren't you reading this yeah so
we got why aren't you doing your work it
got me out of psych eval but I still got
in trouble for like I did I got uh
docked all the points from the past
papers oh that's unfair you couldn't
negotiated with there I'm like there's
not my fault this proves you don't read
our [ __ ] yeah yeah [ __ ] that teacher
yeah you're just a hacker that exposed
the the hole she should be thanking you
that is I do think about that though
like wouldn't it be cool to have blanks
[Music]
foreign
[Music]